[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com so one of the moves that we
knew the trump administration would be
trying to make pretty quickly after
trump's inauguration was to move the
embassy of the united states in israel
from Tel Aviv to Jerusalem and I've
explained why this is an absolutely
terrible idea and the gist of it is that
within Israel there are of course many
people that consider Jerusalem to be the
capital of the country but
internationally Jerusalem is a disputed
territory it's sort of like if
internationally Washington DC was the
capital of the United States but imagine
that internally we sort of thought that
New York was our capital but we were in
a land dispute with Canada / New York
right sort of an analogous situation an
imaginary analogy currently West
Jerusalem is considered part of Israel
East Jerusalem is considered part of the
Palestinian territories with the old
city within that under Israeli control
but with a particular part of the old
city with jurisdiction given back to the
Palestinian Authority very complicated
situation but the long and short of it
is that the future of Jerusalem is by
all reasonable accounts part of what
would be negotiated in a peace agreement
hypothetically if we ever got to that
point again and of course with Jared
Kushner leading that crusade doesn't
seem like we're gonna get there anytime
soon so internationally Tel Aviv is the
capital of Israel that's where the
United States has had its embassy Donald
Trump's choice for ambassador to Israel
we learned pretty early on was going to
be and eventually it became David
Friedman and as soon as we knew that
David Friedman was going to be the guy
to be the US ambassador to Israel we
knew that a top priority would be to
move the embassy to Jerusalem Friedman
is the epitome of a right-wing extremist
on the issue of Israel he is of the
mindset that more settlements are good
which is in the spectrum of views on
settlements to really understand how
wacky that position is you've got to
understand what the sort of range of
positions is and the range tends to be
something like demolish all settlements
and get out completely give that land
back to Palestinians stop building new
ones but presume that existing
settlements may be allowed to stay if
there are meaningful land swaps in
exchange as part of a peace agreement
get the the current settlements to stay
but only if there's some kind of
integration with Palestinians right
there's all these sort of different
views the extremist view is not only are
the settlements not a problem but we
should be building even more settlements
and that's the view of Donald Trump's
ambassador to Israel David Freedman so
completely retrograde on that issue and
Trump has been touting that moving the
embassy to Jerusalem will actually be a
good thing with respect to possible
peace talks between Israelis and
Palestinians because it'll take
Jerusalem off the table right Trump's
idea is listen right now the issue of
Jerusalem is a negotiating issue if we
just move the embassy to Jerusalem and
more importantly recognize Jerusalem as
the capital of Israel we're taking it
off the table for future negotiations
and of course I cannot imagine a more
short-sighted and childish view of the
situation the unilateral decision to
move the embassy without it being part
of an agreement is only going to inflame
the situation and make it more difficult
to even get people to the table to do
the negotiation and of course violence
is escalating completely predictably at
least 25 already dead in the Gaza Strip
in the midst of growing protests against
this move of the embassy Hamas of course
benefiting greatly vowing even more
protest tomorrow mas as I've told you
always acting with no regard whatsoever
for the safety of the Palestinian people
and this will in turn be used to justify
even more pushback by Israeli forces and
the cycle continues this
endless cycle and at the end of the day
we see who it is that influences Donald
Trump its Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu a vile right-winger connected
to the most extreme elements of the
Israeli political spectrum he has gotten
just major concessions from Trump over
the last several weeks
Trump has announced that he's going to
pull the United States out of the Iran
deal which Netanyahu of course loves
hearing from Donald Trump it's a totally
backwards move geopolitically Trump now
following through on moving the embassy
to Jerusalem initially a sort of
provisional embassy with a bigger
build-out coming in the future that's
another move that strengthens Benjamin
Netanyahu's hardliner stands and at this
point I'm genuinely unsure about whether
Netanyahu has even offered Donald Trump
anything in response for all of this
right in other words did Netanyahu
simply manipulate Trump into doing what
he wants Trump to do without having to
offer anything or is there some quid pro
quo here right either real or promised
or hypothetical going on in the
background it's possible that there is a
quid pro quo it's also very possible
that Donald Trump has merely done this
because he's convinced that it's the
correct or cool thing to do and Benjamin
Netanyahu has bamboozled him into doing
it and when we talk about the future of
Benjamin Netanyahu in Israel a guy who
is the subject of multiple criminal
investigations a guy whose wife is also
being looked into for criminal activity
it's the type of guy Trump loves right
Benjamin Netanyahu is in the direction
although not clearly as far as people
like Rodrigo Duterte
and president air Dewan of Turkey and
Kim jong-un of North Korea these are the
types that Trump likes and that's why
it's not even remotely surprising that
Netanyahu seems to have Owen Putin who
can forget Putin Netanyahu seems to have
Donald Trump effectively wrapped around
his finger disastrous decision made here
and I'm sure we'll continue to talk
about the horrible consequences over the
coming weeks and months let's reset
what's going on with Crump attorney
Michael Cohen we learned last week
because of initially tweets from stormy
Daniels attorney Michael avenatti
learned that Michael Cohen through a
shell company called essential
consultants was the recipient of more
than a million dollars that we know of
specifically and allegedly of more than
four million dollars of basically
influence money $600,000 from AT&T 1.2
million dollars from big from Switzer
pharmaceutical company Novartis
reportedly $500,000 from a Putin
connected Russian business owner
billionaire and allegedly many many
other transfers of money and supposedly
the reason that these companies were
paying Michael Cohen's a consulting firm
was for insights into the Trump
administration and of course the timing
was very suspect the timing of the AT&T
money 600,000 not 200,000 as originally
reported coincided with not only the
repeal of net neutrality by the Trump
FCC but also with the fact that AT&T was
trying to merge with Time Warner The
Washington Post has now obtained
internal AT&T documents meaning this is
what AT&T wrote internally about the
real reasons why they were paying money
to Michael Cohen and the internal
documents from AT&T indicate that hiring
Michael Cohen was done to help with the
Time Warner merger AT&T hired the
personal attorney of the President of
the United States to provide advice
about a merger which Trump's own
Department of Justice would be
adjudicating so this is a story about
corruption fundamentally it should not
be a partisan story because corruption
cuts both ways much like freedom of the
press and it can be very tempting to
look the other way
when the lack of press freedom or of
corrosive corruption is helping your
side but that's how we end up screwing
ourselves in the long run and this is
quickly growing to the level of I mean I
don't know to pick an example the
corruption during the presidency of
ulysses s grant which was considered
huge right it included Black Friday
it included a major railroad scam it
included the whiskey ring pond-scum
corruption and cronyism what we are
seeing now under the Trump
administration in terms of
RUP ssin and cronyism is rising above
and beyond even what we saw under
president ulysses s grant and this is
circumstantial evidence of bribery right
the AT&T hiring of michael cohen
Novartis the other companies were
learning about and it's not about
bribery the crime yet but it is deduced
evidence of intent to bribe and receive
bribes and it has to be looked into and
Americans should be united on this
they're not and that is really one of
the scariest things that we're seeing
about the looking the other way on Trump
Russia looking the other way on the
cronyism looking the other way on the
broader bamboozling that has taken place
because this has every indication of
being pay-to-play
which by the way Trump said was a reason
not to vote for Hillary selling access
directly or indirectly explicitly or
implicitly to the President of the
United States and we only have the
information so far about some of the
more than four million dollars that
supposedly ran through this one company
of Cohen's
essential consultants I would be willing
to bet that there is much more and I
hope that we learn about it soon and and
it's important I mentioned legally right
some will say okay AT&T paid Cohen to
help get the merger approved Trump hates
CNN owned by Time Warner Trump opposed
the deal anyway
is it still illegal is it still bribery
even if it wasn't successful bribery and
the answer from legal experts is yes the
offer of a quid pro quo is what makes it
bribery taking money to help get a
merger through getting screwed because
Trump's Justice Department ended up
opposing it doesn't excuse the bribery
we could call it stupid bribery we could
call it failed bribery but it is still
bribery and of course whether there's
going to be any legal repercussions
remains to be seen I am really
disappointed that we're not seeing both
sides put their foot down and say this
is not democracy right and because
corruption is everywhere in our politics
it's unclear as to whether or not
Michael Cohen even committed a crime
here but if he did commit a crime you
have to imagine that Robert Miller
use that to his advantage because he
already has Michael Cohen at the palm of
his hand right if you would think with
the Russia stuff and the stormy Daniel
stuff he could use this as leverage to
maybe that would cause Michael Cohen to
flip on Trump that's increasingly the
discussion I mean we've known that Cohen
has been a likely in Die T of robert
muller for a while and at this point the
questions are number one is this
something molar is concerned with we
believe the answer is yes because we
know Cohen's spoke to both AT&T and
Novartis months ago so clearly Cohen
knows about this question too is there a
point at which Michael Cohen's supposed
the love of Donald Trump just thinking
he's just the best guy out there is
there a point at which it was even going
it would become too much pressure even
on Cohen and Cohen does flip I don't
know the answer to that but it is
something that we may soon learn send me
your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show and boy do we have a good program
for you today the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com want to say thanks to a
couple of great people charles bad is
today's new member of the day membership
is our primary source of funding you can
learn more at join pakman.com also want
to thank Steven McLoughlin who's been a
member since 2012 long term member of
the day thanks to Charles thanks to
Steven thanks to everybody who supports
our work get all the member benefits by
joining a join pakman.com you can also
make a pledge on patreon at patreon.com
slash david pakman show and very quickly
Tom Baker is has donated half of 15
memberships so normal yearly membership
is 60 bucks Tom got in touch over the
weekend said David I want to pay for
half of 15 memberships he has already
done that meaning that there are fifteen
half-price memberships available to you
okay Tom's already paid for half if you
want to pay thirty bucks you get a year
membership at half price
you can keep that half-price membership
as long as you want just get in touch
with me through our website contact form
go to david pakman.com click on contact
get in touch with me say I want one of
Tom Baker's memberships 15 of these are
available and I will send out coupon
codes in order of received emails ok
during the 2016 presidential campaign
Donald Trump campaigned on
pharmaceutical drug prices being too
high and that one of his priorities was
gonna be to negotiate lower prices he
was going to be tough it was gonna be
great for consumers great for patients
great for everybody except the drug
companies and of course that quickly
changed when right after winning the
election Trump met with a bunch of big
pharma
executives and lobbyists and he came out
of that meeting and all of a sudden he
wasn't concerned about drug prices
anymore and now he's gone completely in
the other direction saying that in other
countries governments have negotiated
drug prices that are simply too low and
he's calling it the extortion of big
pharma Trump said that quote it's time
to end the
freeloading once and for all and that
the price controls that other countries
have negotiated with Big Pharma are
quote extortion of quote unreasonably
low prices from drug makers what's the
point of all this why is Trump even
talking about this the reason is Trump
is arguing that if other countries
didn't extort low prices from Big Pharma
the US would have cheaper prices because
we wouldn't be subsidizing the low
prices of other countries and this is
one of the most simplistic and naive
views of drug pricing that I've maybe
ever heard from a president Trump's
basically saying if you allow drug
makers to charge more in other countries
they'd say hey you know what we're
making more in other countries let's
lower prices here in the US since after
all we don't need to make all that money
after all what are we for-profit
companies oh yeah we are and this is
ridiculous at its face and experts agree
it's ridiculous as a professor of a
health policy Paul Ginsburg who says the
obvious which is Big Pharma sets prices
to maximize profits right they will
charge the most they can profitably
charge in Europe and then they will
charge the most that they can profitably
charge in the United States if they can
charge more in Europe or Asia or South
America they will and they'll make more
money and they're not going to then
charge less in the United States because
they're making more money in Europe or
Asia or South America and in fact the
market recognized this because when
Trump said this thing which effectively
means let's get prices up in other
countries the market thought this was
great and pharmaceutical company stock
prices jumped right if this was really
zero some if as prices went up in Europe
they were to come down in the United
States if that was expected you wouldn't
see the markets so excited over Donald
Trump talking about pushing up big
pharmaceutical prices in other countries
the reason the stocks went up is that
this will be a net gain they'll charge a
lot in the United States and they'll
charge more in other countries and truly
think about how dumb this argument is
right Trump saying that the low prices
in other countries are extortion
pharmaceutical companies aren't forced
to do business in other countries if the
prices in France for example
were too low then any pharmaceutical
company could say we're not going to do
business in France anymore because we're
losing money if they're making enough
money in those other countries to
continue doing business there clearly
it's to their advantage to continue
doing business and this also by the way
I was thinking of the horrible timing of
this we just found out that 1.2 million
dollars flowed from Novartis to Trump's
lawyer Michael Cohen for insights into
the Trump administration not exactly the
best time for Trump to be talking about
bringing drug prices up right when it
when we find out that actually his
personal attorney was receiving all
sorts of money from Novartis for health
care policy work as we learned last week
and when Trump said he was going to
negotiate lower drug prices for
Americans I guess what he meant was
force prices up in other parts of the
world so that Americans won't think
they're getting screwed anymore because
the prices will be really high
everywhere I I genuinely don't know but
that appears to be his idea this guy
said that wages are too high in America
and steel still he got elected you know
this isn't really a surprise now not not
a surprise at all and shocking the con
man isn't really going to lower drug
prices here in the United States we've
talked about the Trump presidency as the
sword of Fox News presidency Trump
watches Fox News in the morning Fox and
Friends his first tweets of the day are
often based on what was covered on Fox
and Friends that morning we also know
that Trump shares an advisor with Sean
Hannity in attorney Michael Cohen
whether or not Cohen was ever officially
representing Sean Hannity in a legal
capacity we don't really know but we
know that Cohen and Hannity are in touch
and that Hannity has obtained advice
from Cohen so a lot of connections
between Trump and Fox News and there's
now a new report from New York Magazine
which points out that on many nights of
the week Trump and Hannity are having
oddly enough bed time phone calls Trump
is effectively being put to bed by Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity and
Hannity is reportedly on a list of
cleared friends and family at the White
House switchboard he gets right through
to Donald Trump when he calls and
Trump's routine is increasingly becoming
clear on a day to day
in the morning Trump will watch Fox News
and tweet on the basis of what it is he
sees on TV he watches Fox and Friends in
the evenings he talks to Sean Hannity
and I was thinking as I read this very
interesting article in New York magazine
could the contrast be starter to
President Obama who would read as much
as possible he would read fiction and
nonfiction on his own and he would read
just copious political documents in the
mornings and throughout the day and that
there could be no more antithetical
behavior to that of Barack Obama when it
comes to reading than what we're seeing
from Trump and what New York magazine
also points out is that the morning Fox
and Friends routine is not just Trump's
doing clearly Trump likes watching Fox
and Friends but apparently when Sean
Spicer and Reince Priebus were still
press secretary and chief of staff
respectively they noticed that when
Trump would get up and watch Morning Joe
for example or other channels those had
some less than glowing reports about
Trump and Trump would get so agitated
that it would throw off his entire day
so what Priebus and Spicer decided in a
sense it's brilliant was get Trump to
watch Fox and Friends in the morning
because it keeps him more calm and
stable because they mostly just talk
about how great Trump is this is like
managing a little kid right it's like
he's got the two of the two times a day
propaganda file to placate him he's
deliberately been transitioned by staff
off of morning xuxa
morning Joe over to Fox & Friends it's
like dealing with either a kid or a
developmentally delayed adult yeah at
the beginning of his presidency it
wasn't great that he was only watching
cable news right wasn't really reading
articles or getting those presidential
daily briefing sure but at least he was
getting somewhat of a diversity of
opinions like you had people in the
center you had people on the Left who
criticized them and then you had Fox
News sure now it's just Fox News it's
exclusive and the Fox News diet
obviously has its own problems and
current officials are admitting like
here's the problem
Fox News sometimes exaggerates shocking
and they also leave out major stories if
it's a story that at its base isn't a
good story for Trump to be for the
trumpets Fox News will often just not
cover it so Trump becomes fixated
because of his Fox News diet on small
insignificant stories that Fox News
focuses on and is
completely in the dark about actual
major stories that are relevant in the
grand scheme of things so it's very very
disturbing what's going on with Crump's
media diet but to get back to the
Hannity phone calls for a second
Hannity's role is a little different
than Fox and Friends Hannity's calls
with Trump often leave Trump feeling
like he's just making the right decision
about everything right he's he Hannity
pumps him up to think he's accomplished
amazing things Trump will come away from
these phone calls with Hannity with new
ideas for executive orders he wants to
put through and a former White House
official calls the Hannity phone calls
and effed-up feedback loop that really
messes with Trump's head so the big
picture is Hannity and Fox and friends
are running our country Fox News
Corporation President Rupert Murdoch
reportedly also on that list of people
who can get right through at the White
House switchboard to Donald Trump and
there's really just no comparison to
what's happening at the White House and
I was just thinking you know George W
Bush is really benefiting from Donald
Trump being president and the Washington
Post put out an article to that extent
and it is stunning i mean george w bush
was a terrible president right he made
some of the worst political decisions in
a long time disastrous economy went to
war under false pretenses led to
thousands tens of thousands of civilian
and military deaths and the approval
rating retrospectively for george w bush
is way up because the contrast to donald
trump makes people say hey you know Bush
bush wasn't really that bad and that's
dangerous number one because I've talked
before about the last thing we want to
do is get fooled into seeing the
disastrous neocon Bush doctrine of the
project for a new American Century as
anything short of horrifying but it's
true that compared to what were say mean
but Bush at least read books right it
they weren't the books I might have
chosen necessarily but the guy was at
least reading so this is really really
scary stuff and by the way yet another
link between the Trump administration
and Julian Assange remember that Julian
Assange was in touch with Donald Trump
jr. during the campaign who of course is
directly linked to Donald Trump Julian
Assange was also in touch with Sean
Hannity during the campaign which is yet
another way in which it's completely
that the Trump administration was in
touch with Assange and it's another
mutual point of contact for them just
like Michael Cohen is yeah and one more
thing on Hannity I mean when Hanna he's
done when he show's over at ten o'clock
p.m. yep do you really want to watch
Laura Ingraham or do you want to get the
bonus Hannity and I think that's what
Trump is opting to do yeah where do we
know what Trump thinks about Laura
Ingraham I don't know is that something
I was like yeah onion he hasn't taken a
position yeah that show is unwatchable
by the way and hopefully it'll be off
the air soon I've got an absolutely
horrifying story for you from India
where three teenage girls have been
raped and set on fire during a one-week
period two of them died one left in
critical condition it's believed that
these are three separate cases not
related the perpetrators in the three
cases are different no apparent
connection but I want to talk
specifically about the case of the first
of the three victims the girl was
kidnapped and raped the girl's father
sought retribution through the village
council which is a relatively common
apparatus that exists in some of these
rural parts of India it's a common
system and the council ordered that the
four men who were the perpetrators to do
100 sit-ups each and pay the girl's
family a fine of 700 u.s. dollars this
is a ridiculous penalty to begin with
but then the men were angry that they
had been reported on they broke into the
family home again beat up the victims
parents took the girl set her on fire
and killed her there are now a total of
20 people being investigated for the
attack and officials say that they want
to look at punishing the entire village
for trivializing the rape with this
ridiculous verdict of a hundred sit-ups
and a 700 dollar fine and the story's
been incorrectly reported as the
government gave out a penalty of a
hundred sit-ups and a $700 fine that's
not that's not true right this was one
of these village councils which are part
of the problem and often they look the
other way on honor killings they look
the other way on child marriage and this
is where there are people who are off
the rails with the cultural relativism
topic like with most things life exists
on a sliding scale so very often there's
this conversation it is does do you
believe
and cultural relativism or don't you and
of course the answer is well what are
you talking about right do I believe
that there are any circumstances where
you can defend a hundred sit-ups as a
fine for rape no do I believe there are
any cultural factors that would make it
acceptable to have public beheadings in
Saudi Arabia because hey this is their
culture and we can't judge it no we can
judge it and that's absolutely
ridiculous now do I think that cultural
relativism in a totally benign way can
explain such phenomena as why there are
different breakfast foods in different
countries for example sure and it's just
not really a big deal and it is an
example of cultural relativism do I
believe that hang-ups about nudity that
exist in the US but not in other parts
of the world where beaches are just all
topless is that an example of cultural
relativism that doesn't really require
judgment on our behalf of who what's
better or worse yeah that's a real thing
that's cultural relativism and it's not
a big deal so back to this story those
who claim that it's wrong to say it's
completely ridiculous to leave the
decisions on something like rape of kids
to village councils who might say a
hundred sit-ups and $700 as a fine is
okay no I don't agree with that I think
that it is completely cut and dry that
this is unacceptable and this is why
I've said before coming up with the
principles for your life is fine but the
real tough part is applying it and in
this case saying we believe in cultural
volatile cultural relativism or that we
don't is not really that useful to us
knowing where to draw the line is what's
useful and it's difficult honor killings
and sit-up punishments for rape that's
very clearly on the other side of the
line nudity at beaches in front of
little kids or swearing on TV at any
time of the day breakfast foods that's
clearly on this side of the line and the
problem in practice is where do you draw
the line and as far as India is
concerned a lot of these rural areas
have the village councils they're so
rural that there's very little law
enforcement very little judicial
presence so it's not quite so simple
if you could do it politically to say
the village council is no longer going
to be the sort of law enforcement
apparatus so as with most things it's
more complex in practice but morally
there is absolutely nothing complicated
here discuss this with us on our
subreddit david pakman.com slash r + e
di t the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome back to the david
pakman show it's great to be joined
today by jeremy bamberg who's a
professor of nanoscience at the
university of cambridge also author of
the new book the secret life of science
jeremy it's so great to talk to you one
place i want to start is one that we've
been discussing for a long time and it
relates to a talking point that you
sometimes hear thrown about in popular
culture that for some route people a
science is equivalent to a religion that
it works like a religion and one of the
most interesting things about science to
me that really differentiates it from
religion aside from all of the other
obvious ways is that rather than sort of
creating an echo chamber it actually
encourages the disproof of what are
often considered the sort of common
sense or accepted explanations for
phenomena in fact there's sort of like
great rewards for doing so and you
address that in the book but you also
point out that that sort of free-market
wild west element of science can really
narrow the focus of many scientists so
let's start maybe there talk a little
bit about how you believe the science
world is functioning in general at this
time ok it's a really interesting
question because it combines I guess two
aspects that scientists like one of them
is this sense of a mainstream something
that everybody agrees on that is very
robust I think that's what's one of the
amazing things about science that
really doesn't make it a religion that
is generally even though people might
have sometimes maverick results that
might even get published actually what
happens is this this huge amount of
science which is is building in
different directions it's that it's like
I saw I imagine like a big web of us a
forest of tree trunks enormous things
and if you add something that doesn't
fit it just gets papered over and lost
and and really the thing is incredibly
robust otherwise everything would come
crashing down at the same time as you
say in this sort of competitive system
that we have there are huge rewards for
showing that something is completely
different so trying to build a new
branch in a completely different
direction instead of an empty void that
was never there before and the the
interesting thing is how difficult it is
to do that and you have to convince
everybody because you start growing a
little sapling in some particular area
and if it really isn't robust it just
falls off it withers away but that's how
science sort of works is that some of
these ideas actually are correct and
then we build on them and the whole
enterprise incorporates that into the
fabric so I think that the strong thing
about a disease it evolves it's not
completely static it does evolve and for
that you know this this web of really
strong results is one of the strong
things about science was what's in good
shape and yet at the same time the
competition encourages people to find
something different something new that
will gain them huge notoriety and
therefore success but they have to
convince everybody else that that's
correct so um that the tension between
those sides is partly good what we might
ask is of the money of the huge amount
of resources we put into science are we
using it most efficiently to find those
new places yet that always seems to be I
mean here in the United States as I'm
sure you're aware there is a political
movement which likes to focus on such
financial subjects as waste and debt and
government spending and it's become very
very popular to find very particular
scientific projects that look at you
know the mating rituals of the manatee
only during April of odd numbered years
right I mean of course that's not a real
one
it's obviously it's always caricatures
right but my favorite example is
actually showing does moonlight make
plants grow very often very small about
these are presented as sort of examples
of where science is doing something
that's of no purpose or use or
significance whatsoever and I'm curious
what your sense is of when when that is
brought up does it make sense to argue
the merits of the particular scientific
endeavor or is there some broader meta
argument that is more logical in those
conversations I think the first thing
that's very important is that there is
lots of investment in science research
and science that just wouldn't happen
without our government's funding it and
it happened it's more and more the case
it used to be that we had big corporate
labs high tech I had enough funding to
actually go off and research things in
new directions and and because Finance
is trying to be so efficient all of this
has gone so companies have almost zero
to really invest in in research a few
big giants are able to go in certain
areas and they make big noise about it I
used to work for Hitachi and that was
the same thing they had a large amount
of you know money and a small amount was
invested in really long range and
science projects which are impressive
but by and large it's only really
government funding that produces the
ideas that then can be taken forward
that for me is the thing to really
concentrate on now the difficulty is if
we knew how to choose which projects we
which you know were the good the good
ones then there would be no problem then
industry could just choose it if the
difficulty is when we do science we
really don't know how it's going to pan
out there's a large amount of risk
involved so we have to fund in different
directions and the question is how do we
create a system which is most likely to
choose directions that will show these
new directions you know and unusual ones
as well as take the things that we want
to improve forward with a life highest
likelihood and because of the risky
nature of science that's a really
difficult thing many scientists you know
many people will say oh we can pick the
winners but generally people can't pick
winners there's a large
of randomness involved so you know
scientists often complain that their
grant was not funded but it's actually
even more difficult to try and decide
from a huge array of grants which can
fund maybe a few percent of them which
ones are the best investment for our
society and generally some just do
approach that in a you know in a very
impressive way but I actually in the end
is very difficult to do it and that's
why some of these other examples come
around where it doesn't sound like why
did somebody choose this sort of project
do you think that in some sense science
is expanding in a way that is not the
optimal way so one of the things that
surprised me in in this book I actually
started this book with no preconceptions
at all I just started to try and track
down some answers to the questions that
I was experiencing or people around me
would complain about this or that and I
was figured well it's your system you
know why don't you change it it's it's
nobody's making us do it this way and as
I started to try and understand it I
came across some things which were I
didn't expect to find them and I it
turns out that most people don't know
about them so one of the things that I
think is is quite important to realize
is how the number of scientist is
increasing so if I ask people you know
is the number of physicists in the world
going up or the number of chemists I
mean most most I just don't know
suddenly the general public doesn't know
but actually it's increasing at about 4%
a year it's about four times the world's
population increase so the world
population is increasing by less than
the percent now and dropping quite fast
but a lot of scientists has been
carrying on at this growth rate for over
50 years and shows no signs of stopping
at all and then there's an interesting
question what what happens as you put
more people into science it doesn't
sound like a good idea most more
scientists should give you more science
more breakthroughs and more development
it's not clear it works like that
generally when you put more scientists
into science they don't do all radically
different things they tend to clump
around particular areas that are so hot
what we call bandwagon areas so they end
up sort of often replicating each
other's work or competing very intensely
but to try and do the same things and
that's part of this ecosystem is
competence
that is huge and ferocious within
science community so the difficult thing
I think is at some point clearly they're
going to be too many scientists you know
there probably were too few scientists
in the past but the question is how do
we decide what's the right number of
scientists we might say well the free
market will just decide you know at a
certain point our societies will decide
well that's the number of scientists
that we can fund we don't just fund them
in in you know academia universities
also industry funds a huge number of
scientists about half the number in the
world or a little bit more or actually
within industry and so we're paying for
them through the products that we buy
and that might be you know medical
advances in a very large way these these
are these investment is coming from a
whole range of different directions but
still at the same time we're paying for
them so at some point we might say well
you know it'll just we'll just stop
doing that
interestingly it seems for most
societies when the number of scientists
is a few percent he rises to a certain
amount of the GDP and it stops and I
always sort of joked that the reason it
stops is because if you if you write a
single page of what the country spends
its money on science funding stops when
it actually appears on that page because
it's got large enough it's something
like you know a fraction of the medical
budget a tenth or something like that
and it's because then people say well
what are we getting for our money and
it's very hard to decide because it's a
very long term investment those lines
Jeremy what I mean two things I'm
thinking of if I hear you saying this
are so you've got the increase in the
number of scientists of four percent
which you cited would your view of that
be different if number one funding for
science increased in parallel with the
increase in the number of scientists
because it seems if you increase the
number of scientists and not the funding
you're just taking the same amount of
funding and splitting it into smaller
and smaller pieces but also if there was
some mechanism to make sure that the
areas of focus are diversified rather
than this sort of clustering around the
same the same areas so both of these I
think are very important so scientists
themselves will tell you that it's
harder and harder to get funding and
there's some truth in it but of course
the budgets for science have always been
going up as far as I can see they've
never gone
they are not I mean they're generally
keeping pace also with a number of
scientists but they're very unequally
spread what's happened is also the
aspiration of scientists to do more more
work has increased faster than the rate
of funding so and that's partly because
of globalization actually so scientists
used to work in a smaller community
maybe their national community maybe
even their smaller field and now they
see they're exposed to science from all
around the world and that's in the media
we want to see more more science as well
but more more interested in it so
scientists aspirations for what makes
great impact for breakthroughs has gone
up enormously so they want more
resources to do that so partly it might
be resetting some of that or deciding
how we're going to do that um the other
side of it as you say is how do we
increase the diversity so one of the
things I think it's really a you know a
good way to look at science is like an
ecosystem like a natural ecosystem one
of the things we learn from natural
ecosystems is that if everything is done
the same way if if there is a dominance
of a particular species or a particular
food chain in that system
it loses resilience and its diversity is
contracting and it's a big problem for
that system in the long term one of the
things I now feel about the science
ecosystem is the globalization is not
wholly good because what happens is
people use more more best practice so
the way of funding science in the u.s.
is becoming more more likely where we
fund science in UK or the EU or in China
because people copy the same models and
so the same things get funded everywhere
to the same extent and the problem is
then a lack of diversity so some way to
reset that would be good so actually I I
joked also than the University I'm in
charge of creating anarchy so I think
anak is extremely important or you might
call it diversity so different ways of
actually funding science so we just need
more more examples of this and thinking
of ways to enhance this change within
the system the book is fascinating it's
called the secret life of science we've
been speaking with the book's author
Jeremy Bamber who's professor of
nanoscience at the University of
Cambridge
not Cambridge Massachusetts three miles
from our studio but Cambridge England of
course Jeremy thank you so much for
talking to me today thank you very much
right let's go the david pakman show at
david pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
so I've got a not great update on the
coin base hack I don't want to retell
the entire story because a lot of people
have heard it several times already but
basically last week we were hacked and
several thousand dollars in
cryptocurrency that we had received for
some advertising deals a were was stolen
from our coin base account there was a
huge back-and-forth of about six days a
security investigation coin base has
both changed their policy about publicly
asking for support ticket numbers via
Twitter which was sort of how all of
this started if you look at the coin
base support Twitter account you'll see
they now are asking for those via direct
message they've also changed their if
you go to the page where you submit a
support ticket they haven't read a
paragraph specifically related to how
the hack against us took place so
clearly they've decided that to some
degree the old policy was a liability
because they changed it but they've also
decided quite simply that their review
of our case is over and they're not
compensating us period so we kind of
have two choices we can move on with our
lives or we can try to create a problem
for them would be difficult really to
create a problem for them we're one of
more than 20 million coin based
customers we spoke to our attorney he
said listen I can send a legal letter
but it's probably a waste of time and
money because it's not really going to
do much at this point and it's not even
clear we can create a big enough sort of
public PR problem for them to make a
difference now interestingly I decided
to research the addresses that did the
hacking of course these addresses these
cryptocurrency addresses are anonymous
in the sense that we don't know the
names of the people associated with them
or the bank accounts associated with
them but what I was able to identify was
a series of sort of shell crypto
addresses feeding into one primary
address that has received about 1
million dollars in aetherium
cryptocurrency of late so when you see
the fact that the people that stole from
us have transacted about a million
dollars in crypto recently this is not
in a sense it's not a tiny
operation although compared to the
massive hacks that took place at the
exchange level Mount Cox and others a
million dollars is not very much but
we're talking about the theft of a few
thousand here and there adding up to a
million dollars this is many many
individual transactions and of course
statistically I'm sure many of those
were coinbase users not all of them more
than likely we are not going to have
much of a choice but to move on so we
will continue growing our support
through membership through patreon and
one thing we do have going on Tom Baker
who's been a longtime supporter of the
show he got in touch over the weekend
said David I want to help in some way
with the coinbase hack let me contribute
and do a sponsorship of half of 15 david
pakman show membership so what tom has
done is he's prepaid $30 for 15 people
and what that will now allow is 15 of
you to get a half-price membership
that'll get you the bonus show that'll
get you the daily commercial free audio
and video streams of the show first-come
first-served email in through our
website david pakman.com say hey I want
one of Tom Baker's memberships I'll send
you a coupon code and the best part of
all of this other than paying half price
once is that you can keep the half-price
membership as long as you want you can
renew at half-price indefinitely or ad
nauseam as the case may be from some of
you just get in touch say hey give me
one of those Tom Baker memberships at
half-price David we've interviewed
anti-gay pastor Scott lively before on
the program he is known for helping
Uganda try to put together one of those
kill the gays laws and he's been a sort
of perennial candidate for governor here
in Massachusetts think he also ran for
Senate here in Massachusetts some time
with that I remember him running for
governor against Charlie Baker and in
the past yeah general election he's run
a few times and he's once again running
he's received enough enough support at
the Massachusetts Republican Party state
convention to be on the ballot in their
primary so now anti-gay pastor Scott
lively is in a primary battle against
the incumbent Republican governor of
Massachusetts Charlie Baker
I couldn't possibly summarize Scot
Lively's outrageous beliefs in one
segment but one highlight and check out
my interview with him for some others
one highlight is that Scott lively wrote
in a book in 1995 that the Nazi Party
was controlled by militaristic gay guys
who were really the ones that wanted to
kill the Jews and just just a little
sampling of his views lively received
the support of six hundred and twenty
six of the more than 2,000 delegates to
the Massachusetts Republican state
convention that is twice the requirement
to get on the ballot and obviously Scott
lively is not going to win the primary
Charlie Baker is popular in
Massachusetts he's very popular among
Republicans he's even sort of popular
among some Democrats he's a sort of
decaf Republican in a sense not a guy
I'd vote for certainly not a Democrat
but in many states as a Republican he
would be way too far to the left to win
any Republican primaries and that is
really what I want to talk about not
only Scott Lively's insane beliefs there
is this dynamic in Massachusetts that
people in other states may not
understand Massachusetts obviously a
pretty blue state there's a situation
here where more extreme Republicans can
do okay in Massachusetts early on
because just like in most places some
portion of the electorate are dangerous
extremists and of course these
extremists gravitate towards the
Republican Party in general that tends
to be the place more than the Democratic
Party were the xenophobes and the
homophobes and the conspiracy theorists
can get some support and if the
mainstream Republican Party here in
Massachusetts were bigger those
extremists would be a smaller percentage
of the Republican state convention
because the Republican Party in
Massachusetts is relatively small that
tiny base of extremists have a sort of
comparatively high amount of power the
other reason that lively received again
comparatively high levels of support at
the convention is because Charlie Baker
is so popular among Republicans in
Massachusetts that any so-called normal
Republican to the extent that they exist
they're not trying
run against Charlie Baker right that
means that the nan Baker vote was almost
exclusively coalesced around this
outrageous extremist Scott lively so
that it's a weird thing with
Massachusetts Republicans and even the
history of Massachusetts electing
Republican governors even though we vote
for Democrats in presidential elections
it's it's a it's a unique thing that you
don't see around the country in general
you don't even see it in a lot of blue
states actually bill welds Mitt Romney
Charlie Baker we do have a long history
of that and remember like I mentioned
before in the last go-around he ran for
governor against Martha Coakley and
Charlie Baker yep
and you know on that to bait stage Baker
and Coakley could kind of just brush him
off because he was the crazy third party
candidate
yeah they didn't really have to directly
respond to him because he had no chance
if it's only Baker and lively on that
debate stage that's gonna legitimize him
because Baker is going to have to
address him there are very few
circumstances which would get me to even
remotely care about the Republican
primary for Massachusetts governor
debates and I hate to admit that
bringing a lunatic extremist onto the
stage would get me to watch but I
actually am curious merely from the
point of view of seeing how Charlie
Baker handles Scott lively what's the
silver lining here it's hard to find one
I guess it's that Scott lively isn't
denying that the Holocaust happened he's
saying it was orchestrated by gay Nazis
so that's something it's not an all-out
denial of the Holocaust is that as some
kind of symbol or not remember that gays
were also killed in the Holocaust
certainly not as targeted as Jews were
but weren't victims to that's part of
the conspiracy that dominantly we've
been fed by the lying fake news or
something like that
would have been actually better for
lively to say it was gay Jews that
orchestrated the whole it why not right
like just just go even further if you
need to we've got a voicemail number
it's two one nine two david p we don't
have a voicemail today we actually today
we have an email i mentioned last week
that there are people pressuring me to
change the format of the show to an
interview only show and i said i think
it wouldn't be good for the show here's
one email i received and i got a lot of
emails like it this one's from Lissette
who said dear david regarding the
discussion about having an interview
show versus a news show
if it were an interview only show I
would immediately cancel my membership
in patreon that said it's not because I
don't enjoy the interviews I do enjoy
most of them very much I'm really
pressed for time and I have to work hard
to listen to your show and bonus show
every day the main reason that I listen
is because I want to hear independent
insights on what's going on the more I
know the more I can talk to others and
help to affect change in these trying to
put it mildly times but I wouldn't make
the time for interviews that I do that I
do to hear your take and analysis of the
news what you said about an interview
format immediately torpedoing the show
sounds about right to me
this was the consensus from people
saying listen David but most people the
format of the show is what has built you
the audience you have it would be
incredibly risky to say hey you know
what let's do a completely different
format altogether so for the time being
we're not doing any change in format but
we will explore mixing in other formats
for individual episodes we've got a
great bonus show today I'm out of time
to tell you what's on it but it's a good
one and we'll talk to you that
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]